hi listeners Jenny here you often ask us
how you can learn more about the topics
we cover and deepen your impact As
Leaders I want to take a quick minute to
suggest one solution Stanford Graduate
School of businesses lead online
business program in this yearlong online
program participants hone fundamental
business skills they connect and tap
into a Global Network and they emerge
with an innovation mindset lead is now
accepting applications through February
7th so go check it out at grow.
stanford.edu
leow to learn
more a fundamental capacity that humans
have is to engage in conversation we
create connection and shared
realities my name is Matt Abrahams and I
teach at Stanford Graduate School of
Business welcome to think fast talk
smart the
podcast today I really look forward to
speaking with Shane omara Shane is a
professor of experimental brain research
at Trinity College in Dublin Ireland and
the director of the Trinity College
Institute of Neuroscience he has written
a number of books his latest is called
Talking Heads the new science of how
conversation shapes our worlds welcome
Shane I'm super excited to chat with you
thank you Matt I'm delighted to be
speaking with you all right let's get
started one of your earlier books is
entitled a brain for business a brain
for life how insights from behavioral
and brain science can change business
and business practice for the better if
you were to pick one actionable Insight
from your book that our listeners could
deploy to change the businesses they
work for for the better what would it be
it would be a very simple and
straightforward one it's to be aware of
the fact that we have systematic biases
in our reasoning these are called
cognitive biases and one particular bias
we have is that we focus on the upside
of the decisions we've made rather than
the possible downsides so a good way to
think about this is to assume that
you've gone with a course of action
assume that it has blown up in your face
and that it has been a complete
catastrophe and sit down and do a
premortem rather than a postmortem and
this might help you avoid questionable
uh decisions about the future of your
business so I am a big advocate for
reflection after communication after
decision- making I love this idea of
doing a
premortem imagining things didn't go
well so it can inform the decisions
you're about to make that's incredibly
helpful takes a little bit of time but I
bet it saves a lot of time on the back
end we know there have been many many
products that have been launched into
the market I can think of New Coke was a
very good example there was a cereal for
children here that had a particular name
that sold very well for many many years
and they relaunched it with a new name
and its sales fell through the floor if
people had sat down ahead of time and
thought these are the good reasons for
going ahead now what it might go wrong
that's a hard thing to do because it's
asking you to get evidence for why your
decision making has been faulty ahead of
something having gone wrong but it's a
really clever way of making sure that
you've tested all the angles before you
commit yourself to a new course of
action certainly sounds very prudent I
appreciate that advice I'd like to
switch now to the topic of your latest
book it's all about conversation and I'm
curious how do you define conversation
and what are the essential ingredients
needed to pull off a successful
conversation for me a conversation is
where we create a shared reality
together by means of communicating with
each other that is most commonly by the
use of spoken language but of course
people can communicate in numerous other
ways by text messages by by using sign
language in all sorts of other ways but
the the essence is that we are creating
a shared reality where we come to share
the same states of emotion we come to
share the same states of memory and we
come to think about the future together
in a new way I like that I like that
it's inviting and collaborating to
create a shared reality that we can then
move forward from are there essential
ingredients that go in to a conversation
so for example to my mind a conversation
involves turn-taking it involves
listening it involves clarifying are
there ingredients that you look at when
you look at conversations so you can
think of conversations on multiple
levels I think turn taking of course is
an essential component of a conversation
when I'm speaking you're anticipating
what I'm going to say you're predicting
when I'm going to stop speaking and
you're going to jump in and you'll do
that with a gap of about a fifth of a
second but but I think there's another
way of thinking about conversation which
goes much beyond the issue of you know
are we breathing in an asynchronous
fashion are you predicting what I'm
saying it much more what we're doing is
we're blending language memory and
imagination together so what we have is
this very high level interaction between
the mentalizing system of my brain and
the mentalizing system of your brain
where we're trying to align our mental
states to make some sort of a prediction
about maybe the present maybe the next
10 seconds maybe something that we're
thinking about doing next year and
that's really for me the key thing is
that we think about these brain systems
for memory for language for prediction
as independent of each other but
actually when you look at them in their
core we humans are social animals are
concerned with what the other person is
thinking and we think about things
collaboratively we think about things
together and we spend an awful lot of
our time in the present moment but in
anticipating the future I love what
you're saying I wish I would have
studied Neuroscience when I was in
graduate school because this is
fascinating to me is it safe to say that
our brains are wired for conversation
that our brains are built to look for
this blending and sinking up with other
people I think it's actually where
humans are concerned possibly one of the
core functions of our brains so we have
very elaborate frontal lobes compared to
other species if you look at the size of
the frontal lobes compared to the rest
of the brain they're actually enormous
and what you see when you scan people
when you look at activity in the brain
when they're engaged in narrative when
they're generating speech or when
they're anticipating what other people
are doing and what we're actively doing
is Imagining the mental state of the
other person and this is a capacity
known as mentalizing and it's core to
the success that humans have because I
can guess what you're thinking you can
come to guess what I'm thinking and on
that shared basis we can move forward
together in a conversation the two of us
are having wow so Are there specific
things that we can do as communicators
to facilitate this blending this
predicting that you're talking about for
example telling stories using emotive
language certain types of words are
there things we can do that facilitate
that connection and speed it up so I'm
going to give you a slightly side angle
view on this uh one of the core
functions of the human memory system is
something called mental time travel and
this is the idea that while we're
centered here in the present uh the two
of us are talking to each
other we can slide backwards in time
what were you doing yesterday what were
you doing two weeks ago or we can slide
forwards and time mentally thinking
about what we're going to do next week
what we're going to do the week after or
even much further out than that and I
think a core thing that really good
speakers focus on is getting people to
decenter from where they are at the
moment and opening out the future to
them in new ways because if you look at
the content of our thought what you find
is about 75% of the content of our
thought is either present centered or
future oriented but we're only able to
engage in this kind of thinking because
we have memory system that we can draw
on that blends seamlessly with our
language system and I think when you
look at the great orators I pick on
Abraham Lincoln you know just as a good
example with his four score and however
many years ago he's calling on the past
but he's calling on the past in a
particular way it's in the service of
the needs of the present and a vision
for the future and allowing people
through the use of evocative language to
Journey backwards to reenter in the
present and then imagine that the future
is going to be better than the present
is I I think something that the great
orators kind of Inuit it already uh and
those of us who aren't so great at at
oratory can take a lesson from in
essence as a communicator we're a guide
that takes people from the past to the
present to the Future and I think if you
listen not just to Great historical
orators but if you listen to Executives
and good leaders they do something very
similar and I love knowing that there is
an actual Neuroscience logic to what
they do and this use of time traveling
and how it ties together the memory
aspects of our brains with the
conversational aspects I think is
fascinating one of the things that I was
fascinated by in learning and
researching you is that you have some
thoughts about gossip gossiping is a
type of conversation that many of us are
familiar with you make the argument that
gossip has some utility how is Gossip
helpful and is there ever a time where
you would actually advise people to
gossip I think gossip gets a bad rap and
it shouldn't we think of Gossip in a
malign sense that one person is telling
stories about another person in a way
that's designed to be injurious to them
to do their reputation some harm but
that's kind of a folk story about gossip
when you actually look at the functions
of gossip and when you measure gossip
when it occurs and many Studies have
looked at this what you find is most
gossip most of the time is helpful it
acts as a kind of an oil in a social
situation it allows us to Interchange
information exchange information with
each other in ways that make us
comfortable with each other but it goes
further than that if you imagine
yourself coming into a new organization
let's say for example you join a a
sports club uh you don't know anybody
but you need to know who gets things
done can you depend on the scheduling
secretary for the matches that you've
signed up for can you depend on the club
secretary for other matters you talk to
the players you'll talk to people people
will feed you uh pieces of information
they'll say Joe does his job very very
well uh Tom does not do his job well at
all and uh you can test the truth of
that you can see whether they're saying
that with viciousness or if there's a
malign intent there or if it's just a
simple statement of reality and the
reason I emphasize this is that when you
consider how complex our societies are
lots of the things that we need to know
about living every day is information
that is tacit in nature it's not written
down you can't find it by doing a search
on the internet you have to ask somebody
and what humans have is this fantastic
facility for focusing on what you need
quickly and then there's a final
function that gossip has which is I
think a positive one we all want to be
taught well of where other people are
concerned we don't want people speaking
ill of us so we might decide not to do
certain things we use the threat of
Gossip to police our own behavior in
other words we find ourselves conforming
to the Moray and Norms of the society we
are in because we're engaging in that
act of anticipation and prediction about
what others might say about us which is
a a really peculiar way of thinking
about gossip because it's gossip that
hasn't happened but it's the fear of the
gossip that might happen that you in the
future that you allow to police your
behavior in the present it's fascinating
to me the various ways in which gossip
can be used especially strategically I
remember a boss I had at one point and
her advice to me before we had a big
restructuring coming in the organization
was to let some indication that that was
coming to some of the people we knew in
our team who did gossip more than others
in other words we were using it as a way
of setting expectations so people
weren't surprised they would have heard
it before so that they could mentally
prepare themselves so gossip serves a
lot of utility and I think it's a tool
that we should all consider obviously
carefully in our strategic
communication now I have a very personal
question for you you wrote a book on the
Neuroscience of interrogation I have two
teenagers who often accuse me of
interrogating them when I ask them
what's going on I personally think my
questions are rather reasonable what
advice would you give people on how to
appropriately yet effectively get
information from people who might not be
open to sharing it so that's a great
question I have a teenager myself and
the mood varies from day to
day and the amount of information that
is offered varies from day to day I
think you know to to speak about
teenagers for a moment teenagers of
course are focused on developing
relations with their peers and parents
are there in a support rather than
leading capacity which was a big
adjustment from just a few years ago
when they were maybe aged eight or nine
or 10 when they looked to you for
everything and you are a source of
authority so that becomes a kind of a
difficult change for the parents to
negotiate the remarkable thing here is
that people are very willing most of the
time to share information about
themselves and what they've been doing
depending on how they are asked and uh a
whole variety of of dat now show that if
you're able to establish a condition of
rapport with another individual that is
you engage an active respectful
listening if you approach the person not
from a position of kind of attempting to
dominate the conversation but one where
there's an obvious attempt to engage in
a respectful Mutual interchange of
information those kinds of conversations
open up very well but there's one point
I would make very often the mistake and
you see this very commonly when
politicians are engaged in questioning
in I don't know Congressional hearings
or parliamentary hearings or whatever
they give a very long opening statement
followed by a very short question
followed by something else if you want
to elicit information small short
focused questions that are detail
oriented are very difficult to evade but
you have to suppress your own tendency
to want to augment the question so if
you ask a question in a respectful way
that's targeted at a particular detail
and you've got a follow-up that follows
on logically from that that's a very
reasonable way to proceed and what you
find is people will open up not
everybody all of the time but most
people most of the time that last point
you made I took notes on and it
reinforces something my wife is
constantly telling me minimal words she
says when I'm talking to my teens I tend
to wax poetic share a lot of information
and you've just supported her point of
view minimal words keep it focused on
something specific your wife is very
wise oh I've said that for a long long
time before we end Shane I'd like to ask
you some questions one I'm making up in
the moment and two that I've asked lots
of other people are you willing to do
that I would love to excellent yet
another book that you wrote was on
walking in nature I'm curious just very
quickly I love to walk myself what are
the psychological benefits of walking so
the argument I make in that book is that
humans are social Walkers and I think
the great benefits of walking are found
when we walk together and we actually
talk while we're walking and the core
message that I have there is that if you
want to get psychological benefits from
a walk do it with another person and
talk to another person you'll feel
connected you'll feel more open to
experience in the the outside world
you'll find your stress hormones drop
there are all sorts of subt and not so
subtle benefits from engaging in walking
with another person we have a term for
that here at Stanford's business school
we call it twalking talking and walking
together oh what a great word I must I
must use that many of us go on tws and
some of my colleagues are quite fast
twers they talk fast and they walk fast
and I'm often out of breath as I chase
them question number two who is a
communicator that you admire and why so
the person I admire is George or Orwell
who was sadly long dead but Orwell was
as clear a writer in the English
language as I think I've ever read his
writing is not adorned Pros it's very
unadorned but it's very simple it's very
straightforward and you know exactly
what he's trying to say and one of the
key themes that Orwell brings up time
and time again is that the use of
language can be a political act and and
that politicians very very often use
language to hide or obscure truths from
us that we really ought to be paying
attention to and he sought in his
writings to be very very clear and
scrupulous in the in the kind of writing
that he engaged in and I've always
admired his writing style as a really
good form of clear communication for
that reason I have admired Orwell's
writing as well and I used to teach a
number of his books to get at those
points that you just alluded to so our
final question what are the first three
ingredients that go into a successful
communication recipe there's an old joke
about Tony Blair the former United
Kingdom prime minister who was asked
what his first three priorities in power
were and he would reply education
education education so I would say
listening listening listening the more
that I do this podcast the more that I
talk to experts like yourself the more
listening comes up it's very very
important and I have to say Shane it was
a true Delight to listen to you I
learned a lot in our conversation I find
it fascinating the blending of our
memory systems and our communication
systems to bring about rich exchange and
shared realities thank you for your time
thank you Matt I appreciate
it thanks for joining us for another
episode of think fast talk smart the
podcast from Stanford Graduate School of
Business
this episode was produced by Jenny Luna
Ryan Campos and me Matt Abrahams our
music was provided by Floyd Wonder for
more information and episodes find us on
YouTube or wherever you get your
podcasts thank you and please make sure
to subscribe and follow us on
LinkedIn